[Musica]
ciao a tutti mi chiamo luca ravenna di
lavoro faccio il comico normalmente o un
microfono in mano la prima volta nella
mia vita che ha un archetto e mi sento
come chi mai dovesse essere capitato
come quei venditori di padelle
particolarmente antiaderenti che si
trovano nei mercati che hanno il
microfono e riescono a parlare a gestire
tre quattro casalinghe in una volta sola
ci tenevo a dire questa cosa perché io
sono ossessionato ossessionato dalle
risate
da quando sono piccolo credo
normalmente quando io scrivo un pezzo
prima di recitar lo dico che sceglie una
cosa che ho di scegli una rivalità da
mettere in gioco con il tuo pubblico di
modo che questa cosa diventi una cosa da
odiare insieme e almeno siamo amici in
qualche modo
siccome qui più o meno pubblico non c'è
ne approfitto per dire è un tipo di
persona che io odio particolarmente che
sono gli scalatori le persone che fanno
arrampicata le persone che votano la
loro vita alla natura e al andare sulle
montagne a fare l'amore con altre
persone che condividono questi interessi
hanno dei corpi bellissimi non fanno che
parlare di tutto questo non fanno che
fracassare le palle alle persone a cui
non interessa questa cosa e ti fanno
sentire anche in colpa perché tu non sei
così amanti della natura in particolare
parlo degli uomini eterosessuali con i
quali riescono empatizzare un po hanno
questa capacità di sembrare persone che
sanno ascoltare cosa che non sono perché
si nascondono dietro i loro orribili
occhiali da sole da marin
ci tenevo a dire questa cosa e non ho
sempre iniziato così miei pezzi e non ho
sempre iniziata così miei pezzi quando
ha iniziato a vivere l'ossessione per la
risata io penso sia iniziato quando ero
piccolo non avevo l'idea di scrivere ma
avevo l'idea di salire su un palco il
mio palcoscenico era la cena di natale
venivano alla famiglia di mia zia a casa
e io passavo le ore in attesa non di
babbo natale ma dicendo o un palco con
le persone condividono i riferimenti se
faccio la zia e la zia
se faccio mia madre e mia madre ma
soprattutto se faccio mio padre è lui e
posso massacrarlo e mi ricordo benissimo
quando una
sera di natale metà anni 90 stavo
facendo un grande show per tutti ea un
certo punto devo aver imitato non ha
idea deve aver preso in giro a mio padre
che lui mi ha guardato e mi ha detto
smettila di fare il gasato ora io parlo
molto spesso nei miei pezzi comici di
mio padre è il rapporto probabilmente
più complesso e affascinante che la mia
vita mio padre non parla un italiano
comprensibile ma parla bofonchiando in
modo comico parla sembra che tutto il
tempo col resto del mondo no con i suoi
figli baby parla di quel giorno è stato
molto chiaro con me mi ha detto smetti
di fare il gasato e mi ha spezzato il
cuore mi ha spezzato il cuore in modo
terrificante ma neanche fatto capire
qual era il mio nuovo ruolo all'interno
della famiglia perché è il comico fino a
quel momento era sempre stato lui il re
assoluto della comicità una persona
pronta a distruggere dei rapporti pur di
fare una battuta aveva trovato aveva
questa cosa fa ridere perché è vera
aveva trovato il suo arcinemico il suo
figlio più piccolo e da quel momento in
poi essere diventato sì un buffone ma
anche la persona che lo sfidava per
sempre poi io abbia deciso di farne un
lavoro per il piacere di mio padre così
che adesso quando carica un video su
internet la gente al è quello che buffon
chi è questo poesia della risata è
bellissimo che abbia deciso di fare il
comico puramente quella sera non lo
sapevo ci ho messo tantissimo tempo
tantissimi anni a capire che avrei
voluto fare queste di lavoro ma mi piace
pensare che sia andata cosi la memoria
aiuta a ricordare questo mi piace
pensare che quello che mi ha soprattutto
spinto a farlo sia stato il limite
imposto da mio padre fino a quanti
promuovere da qui in poi non puoi più
far ridere e mi sembra sia un tema molto
molto interessante e nei nostri in
questo momento e ai nostri tempi
salire sul palco provare a fare delle
battute per me è un'arte nobile essere
il buffone il clown narratore ma anche
un amico un amico al quale perdoniamo
delle battute orribili perché ci fanno
particolarmente ridere però è quella
earth è una cosa bellissima
ma che ci fa non so come dire ci solleva
dal fatto di stare al mondo di essere
delle persone terrificanti
oggi come oggi si si guarda tantissimo
ai limiti imposti da altri spettatori
io come come comico che stare sul palco
ogni tanto percepisco che il pubblico
viene con il fucile un po puntato pronto
dire no scusa non puoi dire mi sembra
una cosa molto libera che loro possono
dirti questo questo era un
articolatissimo gioco di parole per
tenere sempre che dall attenzione è
difficile ragazzi è molto difficile e
per me è molto importante lo spazio del
palco lo spazio che si condivide con il
pubblico ma soprattutto lo spazio della
risata perché è l'unico modo che io ho
trovato nella mia vita
per riuscire ad affrontare dei problemi
emotivi per riuscire soprattutto a
superarli e ancora più di qualsiasi
altra cosa per uscire ad accettare il
fatto di essere una persona spesso
orribile terrificante che fa dei
pensieri che non andrebbero mai
condivisi che è esattamente quello che
fa chiunque nel pubblico e quello che fa
chiunque quando è vivo e adesso la
faccia della terra
secondo me secondo me non sta sbagliando
chi dice il contrario mente di base
non voglio fare gesti cool facendo così
non amano le mani vanno casini io mi son
detto la mia vita cerca di trovare il
modo di farti pagare per dire delle
minchiate
cerca di essere l'amico speciale al
quale concessa la possibilità di dire le
cose orribili che gli altri hanno
pensato molto lentamente
adesso piumino ci sta riuscendo idea la
più grande soddisfazione della mia vita
la cosa più bella è cercare di
trasformare le battute le cattiverie le
risate che tutti quanti diciamo non in
bullismo come spesso accade soprattutto
su internet non so se capitate sentiamo
parlare ma in qualcosa di
intellettualmente diciamo utile e
stimolante a liberarci all'idea di aver
pensato qualcosa di orribile io sono
molto fiero di farlo sul palco ed è
bellissimo quando c'era del pubblico
sotto a condividere questo momento la
cosa a cui tengo di più rispetto allo
stare sul palco il fatto che
uno spazio condiviso nel quale si
accetta l'idea che io faccio battute
sessiste
assolutamente sì razziste cento per
cento omofobe
ma proprio con la vanga perché sono vivo
nel senso perché sono vivo faccio queste
cose
ripeto le faccio io le fa chiunque sia
al mondo
il bello è liberarsi dalle idee di
poterlo fare insieme e succede solo ed
esclusivamente nello spazio della risata
detto questo crescendo è giusto
ammettere ad accettare i limiti del
linguaggio
esattamente come ho fatto con mio padre
mi ha detto non fare il comico detto ok
lo trasformano il mio lavoro se non si
possono dire delle parole è bello
cercare dei modi per spiegare perché
quelle parole ti danno fastidio e
trasformarla in altri
questo perché e attenzione questo grande
collegamento che mi sto preparando a
fare puntando le mani dentro a una
frattura all'interno di una parete come
se fosse uno scalatore era soltanto
un'idea retorica per tornare all'inizio
però io odio gli scalatori mi fanno
schifo come persone perché io vorrei
essere come loro
tutto qua solo loro hanno trovato un
modo più figo per fare l'amore io no e
mi diverto all'idea che quando ci sono
delle fratture quando ci sono delle cose
orribili che noi diciamo e pensiamo il
mio lavoro e se quello di metterci le
dita dentro provare ad arrampicarmi
sulla parete e portarmi dietro tutte le
persone che stanno condividendo lo
spazio in questo caso orizzontale non
verticale che è il momento in cui si
chiacchiera insieme e si ride insieme e
si dice oddio sono orribile su una
persona disgustosa lo sai anche tu
grazie a dio ora possiamo uscire
condividere il fatto che tu a degli
scalatori io sono scalatore ma mi sei
stato simpatico questa lezione l'ha
imparata
vabbè questa la cosa l'ho scritta e mi
sembrava abbastanza brillante però
imparate veramente dicendo quello che ho
detto a mio padre
anzi quello che lui ha detto a me quello
che io ho semplicemente recepito perché
quando si odia qualcosa di qualsiasi
genere qualsiasi termine un qualsiasi
parola venga chiamata spesso perché si
vorrebbe in qualche modo essere quella
cosa quella parola quell'essere umano e
io effettivamente volevo essere il
buffone di corte
e adesso fermano mio padre perché lui
sembra un buffon
grazie mille
[Applauso]